Paulo?
Paulo? Can you trust me?
Oh. Oh, God.
What are you doing?
It's a surprise. Are you ready?
Heh heh heh heh heh.
You're supposed to be in Russia.
Well, they delayed my flight. I mean, I have
a beautiful idea. Let's get married right
here. Friends and family are just the two of
us. Tomorrow, if you want.
Let's do it.
Was that your plan all along?
When everything eventually fell apart, we
would just. We would get married up here on
my rooftop?
I would marry you under a bridge if I had to.
What's going on, Paolo?
I called everywhere.
No one knows anything about our wedding.
Nothing.
Is that what this is about?
Benita, we have important guests that
require discretion.
Our wedding was supposed to be confidential.
What did you expect to find out without me?
What's going on?
You're lying to me.
Why would I lie to you?
And I trusted you with my daughter.
I was getting ready to uproot my entire
f***ing life for a lie.
I made a few mistakes.
And you're still punishing me?
No, no, no, no, I thought we were past.
I looked into everything.
I looked into you.
You looked into me? Yeah.
Why would you look into me?
Why me, Paula?
Why me?
I'm a journalist. You had to know at some
point, I was gonna start asking questions.
Yeah.
That's what I love about you.
That man in Italy had a wife.
Who was your patient?
He wasn't mafia.
He wasn't some stranger.
He wasn't an enemy.
What did you do to them?
There are certain things that you don't want
to have to tell you. You're giving me no
choice. Without my work, what I do.
Is tied to governments heads of state.
Oligarchs. I've been forced to treat some
very bad people.
And you don't want to go digging in there,
Benita, because it's dangerous.
It is dangerous for me.
It is dangerous for you.
And it's dangerous for Lizzie.
What I'm trying to do is to protect you.
Paulo. Paulo, you need to leave.